what is sci-fi and what does it mean to
the two of you huh wow that's an
interesting question that's a big
question well so I think it links on the
science and geek was science fiction
it's a wonderful playground because it
allows it allows us to comment on our
world but in a way that makes it much
more universal now after instance when
Rod Serling came up with twilight zone
he was censored by the networks and
sponsors in terms of saying anything he
wanted to say about politics or race or
social issues of the day so he created
twilight zone so he could comment on
those things without the sensors
removing it and as a result those
Twilight Zone episode timely now in the
Trump era as they ever were when he was
writing and Eisenhower was president or
Kennedy was president so I love the fact
that science fiction allows me to reach
an audience of millions of people around
the world and the work last decades and
actually centuries ultimately and it
also seems to inspire people because
there are so many things that were junk
off from things like Star Trek where
geek you know you kids grow up to be a
scientist and they actually jumped in
and they they made it real so it really
is inspirational and one thing that I
really like about science fiction is
it's the same thing with stories and
small towns or westerns it's where a lot
of the complexity of modern life is
stripped away and we can really focus on
moral and emotional issues in a much
clearer way yes yeah it also could kill
character using the back because you can
call them or whatever I particularly did
it that you have a head in the table
yeah a little video if it's really fun
do you remember the first time the two
of you were exposed to the first sort of
sci-fi story and where you were how old
you were yeah well yeah well what's
going to us I'm the real science fiction
geek I mean elaine was reading
Dostoevsky when she was a kid and my
home and I wanted to robot I want to
robot boy yeah exactly but the my first
experience with science fiction I you
know when I was a kid I was reading
comic books from as early as I can
remember my first favorite book was
farmer in the sky by Robert I'm
and when I was seven I just grew up in
the genre a Twilight Zone Star Trek
Outer Limits those are the three shows
that made me want to be a writer and as
soon as I was a teenager I started going
science fiction conventions and meeting
those writers the writers was written
for those shows harlan ellison bc
fontana david gerald theodore sturgeon
richard matheson George Clayton Johnson
Ray Bradbury and they many of them
became friends and mentors and so I
definitely knew where home was for me
and I was more brought up on a social
older social issues than some of the
older riders like 1984 and and hg wells
were they really exploring social issues
so that was some- already knew the older
ones and my parents gleaned strongly to
the left and said I and so we found
their ability to explore things where
people would not put up walls because
his future allow them a much greater
freedom to reach into people's thought
processes and feelings without defensive
pneus some of it you know the I mean I
just was you know when I was a kid I was
given a Christmas present of a trip to
the Star Trek set so I was there for the
last episode of the original Star Trek
ever shot turnabout intruder so I got to
a suit in the captain's chair and stand
on the transfer I remember looking up
and think it was just a light bulb
screwed into this to transporter above
above my head my head huh watch G and I
remember thinking how small they be I'm
engineering on the Star Trek set was a
forced perspective and I'm singing jesus
is a lot smaller than it looks on
television and it was just an amazing
day really a wonderful wonderful day of
great the best Christmas present ever
you